hi I'm Evan Carmichael welcome to
another edition of ask Evan in today's
episode I'm going to answer a question
from one of my newsletter readers Anna
who is trying to raise fifteen to twenty
thousand dollars to create a new social
networking type of website and go after
investors and one of my advice on how to
do it so I know thanks for the question
I think for you it's a tough amount of
money to raise if you're looking only at
fifteen to twenty thousand
you're not really getting a serious
investor involved you know you're not
getting somebody who has a lot of
experience usually a lot of the angel
guys that would be too low an amount for
them so you might get somebody like a
dentist or a doctor to come in and you
know they have extra cash and would want
to invest but they may not have a lot of
experience and part of bringing money in
is you don't want just money you want
someone who can help you and give you
connections right they're gonna be part
of your ownership team they have equity
in your business so you want them to
give you more than just money you want
them to be a helpful resource for you so
you definitely want to qualify your
investors but it may be too little an
amount to go after a serious investor
the next thing is a lot of people want
to start social media sites so you know
this is this is gonna be a negative
hurdle for you to have to overcome
there's a there's a stigma that a lot of
the social media sites have already been
created and for you know new products or
services it's encouraged to build around
the existing social media sites instead
of trying to build your own new one from
scratch so there are still some examples
of one that have paid it big but deserve
there's a negative bias that you're
gonna have to overcome and really show
how you're different and what's so
unique about you and why you're gonna
make it where all these other you know
startup social media sites have failed I
think a more important issue is you're
raising money to bring on you know a
team to help you you know build this
website so some company that you've
hired to you know they've quoted you for
the website and you're gonna pay them to
do it it's really hard and from an
investor's point of view so I used to be
a venture capitalist
we wouldn't touch a business like this
because you don't have the technology
team in-house so for an investor they
want to see at some point that you're
going to be able to exit
from your business you're gonna be able
to pay them their money back so either
you're gonna go public we're gonna get
acquired or it's gonna be some kind of
management buyout and they look at what
kind of technology do you have in the
house and it's really hard to run a
business without having somebody on the
technology side in-house right
everything is exported to you know
overseas or some other company even if
they're local you don't have the
experience in-house and it's really hard
to grow business that way and really
hard to raise money for that type of
business so what I would encourage you
to do is try to find a partner who
really understands the technology side
of things can build it without having
you give up you know capital win over
the raise capital bring on a jewel
investor try to find a partner who's
committed to it and work around that if
you're able to build up a prototype and
get it going and get some momentum with
it then will be a lot easier to raise
money because you have somebody in-house
you have core competencies you have
intellectual property and you don't have
to keep paying outside companies to
finance your development so I hope that
helps they've been up to news you wanted
to hear but those are my thoughts if you
guys liked the video please give it a
thumbs up below it makes me want to make
more of these videos for you guys and
I'd love to hear you have to think if
you have some comments leave it below in
the comments or if you have a question
as well I can leave it in the comments
below and we'll see you on the next
episode
you